so what would RFK Jr be like as
President part of his appeal to
Libertarians at least is that he's
staunchly anti-war and a huge critic of
coveted walk downs and mandates but he's
fundamentally a big government liberal
he supports Alexandria ocasio-cortez's
Green New Deal he favors heavy-handed
government intrusion in the realm of
Environmental Policy he's anti-nuclear
energy he wants pharmaceutical companies
to burn in hell and he seems to believe
in an almost Alex jones-esque dramatized
concept of the deep State he also favors
massive wealth redistribution I don't
think he's huge disparities and whales
are healthy for our country or healthy
for democracy